are friends over at the good liars
they're really good at this stuff
they talk to people at different
political events they go to anti-vaccine
events they go to trump rallies they go
to all sorts of different things
they were able to find
and how hard they had to look i don't
really know it's probably pretty easy at
these events they found a woman
who believes that joe biden is currently
being played by actors in other words
they're sort of like i guess body
doubles and makeup i don't know and one
of the actors that
this woman believes is playing joe biden
is the great comedic actor jim carrey
let's play it and then we're going to
talk about it and i know that this is
funny in some ways but this is actually
really scary and we'll we'll talk about
that you think biden is not alive right
now no the guy that's doing the stand-up
job of trying to wake people up is an
actor wearing a mask i mean there's
several different people playing joe
biden at this point and when when he
fell up the stairs going on the airplane
i myself think that that was jim carrey
now why would it be jim carrey i don't
know i would love to get an explanation
about that
i've heard that he was one of them
wait wait wait wait you think that jim
carrey was wearing a mask right and
was the acting president and being silly
by falling up the stairs three different
times
and james woods also i think is one of
the
doppelganger mask wearing
people now isn't james what i don't want
to say this incorrectly but i thought
james woods was a republican why would
he be uh
james woods has praised trump yeah i
don't know why james woods would be
willing to be part of the subterfuge so
listen i'm going to take this seriously
i'm going to take this seriously i don't
want to joke about this
it can be really hard to figure out a
diagnosis for folks uh like this i i
spoke to some psychiatrists about this
when we see someone like this and we say
okay is this
is this uh like what is happening here
we try to make sense of how someone
could end up believing stuff like this
one possibility is what's called
delusional disorder you're delusional
okay it's a type of psychosis
where a person can't tell what is real
and what's imagined so as real as this
microphone is for me
the person sees as just just as real
that jim carrey and james woods are
playing the role of biden who has died
and the main feature of delusional
disorder is the presence of delusions
which are truly unshakable beliefs that
something is true and people with
delusional disorder often can continue
to socialize seemingly normally you
could go and have lunch with this woman
and talk about the weather and whatever
and it's the subject of their delusion
where
it's it's just wacky but their other
behavior is not obviously odd or bizarre
like they're not all collecting feces at
home you know or whatever like they just
they live normally but they have these
specific unshakable delusional beliefs
now delusional disorder by itself is
actually pretty rarely diagnosed
it typically occurs
in middle age or later and the causes
can be genetic biological environmental
now that would point to why
people who have one set of delusional
beliefs that they often hold strange
beliefs about a few things but again
they typically function normally now the
other day we mentioned a
different but similar condition it's
called paraphrenia disorder so it might
sound like schizophrenia it's not it's
something different paraphrenia is a
mental disorder characterized by a very
organized system of paranoid delusions
they don't have to have hallucinations
and that typically onset is later in
life 60 plus
and paraphrenia doesn't have its own
section in the dsm-5 because often when
someone
presents with paraphrenia uh they end up
being diagnosed with delusional disorder
so these these are very
blurry lines and they can be hard to
sort of diagnose
this is more common in women
now let's take it a step further again
we're taking this seriously saying do
these people just need to be convinced
or do they need medication we're trying
to really think it through in a serious
manner there's a study that opens the
door even wider
the study is called
belief in conspiracy theories the
predictive role of schizotype
machiavellianism and primary psychopathy
what this study looks at is whether
schizotype machiavellianism
grandiose narcissism vulnerable
narcissism primary psychopathy and
secondary psychopathy
are good predictors of how likely
someone is to believe conspiracy
theories now
this correlation wouldn't necessarily
say to us well if you have someone with
a specific delusional conspiracy theory
like this woman it doesn't guarantee
that they are psychopaths or they are
uh
schizophrenic or whatever the case may
be
but it might have some kind of
predictive role about how likely are
those folks to end up believing some of
these things and then you could kind of
work backwards and try to figure out is
there medication that will help
this is really serious stuff
uh the psychiatrists i've spoken to and
my dad is a psychiatrist have said
um
sometimes
medications can help folks like this
but it is not super typical that if you
give someone who's
quite ill with these types of beliefs a
pill
that four weeks later or eight weeks
later
they no longer believe any of this stuff
the
paranoia or the delusion might be less
intrusive
they might be less focused on it it
might form less of a sort of obsessive
nature for them they might not be at the
trump rallies talking to people
but uh this is still a not
completely well understood area of
mental health
uh now what do we know for sure
there's too much stigma around mental
health treatment in the united states we
have a lot of undiagnosed mental illness
in the united states and we have a lot
of we have not nearly enough access to
mental health treatment and that's part
partially a stigma thing it's partially
a health care system thing and this is
really a big deal but
this goes well beyond politics and i
think that that's the important thing to
understand